CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend spent 13 years
working in the Justice Department she
was homeland security advisor to
President George W Bush good morning the
more you've been through these process I
have yourself many times how unusual is
it to have someone with repeated interim
security clearances with access to this
top-secret security well it's not clear
that he had access to top-secret so he
would have had an interim secret
clearance first he had worked on Capitol
Hill so he's probably been through the
security vetting process before it's
surprising to me given his prior
government experience that he was still
in an interim security clearance
position right and the staff secretary
job normally this is just moving paper
around Norah it's not for example the
president's daily intelligence briefings
in with the director of the CIA so the
staff secretary is not touching the most
sensitive secrets but still the notion
that given Rob Porter's prior government
experience you'd be surprised that he
was still in an interim State if you've
never served in government that's more
understandable that it'll take longer to
get you through the process but it's
clear that this was there were problems
in this investigation people were aware
of that going back too long so the FBI
director made clear they've alerted the
White House many times throughout the
past year they even closed the file in
January does it pass the smell test that
either a deputy chief of staff or the
chief of staff wouldn't know about these
problems it is not possible to me look I
think Sarah Sanders from the podium is
relying on there there's this career
staff in the White House that determines
these security clearances but those
career people Norah they report to
political people so in this case that
office is overseen by the deputy chief
of staff Joe Hagen who sits next to John
Kelly there and they would have alerted
Joe that they were the deputy chief of
staff that there were problems in this
investigation
by the way when they FBI completed it in
July and the White House asked
additional questions the White House
would not have gone back to the FBI to
ask additional questions without
clearance from leadership in the White
House in other words if it had not risen
to something higher than just kind of
career staff that's right and the FBI
John didn't say they had completed it
without running to ground these domestic
abuse allegations so that was resolved
in July
now whatever the White House asks
between July and November fine but those
domestic abuse allegations were
completed and looked into to the
satisfaction the FBI by July what's a
big question that you have well I mean I
think you want to know how many
outstanding in from clearances are they
are now into the second year of the
administration in fairness I will tell
you this administration brought in more
people who had never served in
government and those take longer because
typically if you served in government
before and you come back in you just
have to update your clearance and so but
I think we need to know because they do
have access to sort of all the foreign
policy discussions and the intelligence
that's briefed before those discussions
Fran Townsend always good to have your
expertise thank you